في غضون ذلك اكدت شركه ميرسك تعرض احدى
سفنها القادمه من سنغافوره لحادث بعد
مرورها بمضيق باب المندب واكدت سلامه
افراد طاقم السفينه ومواصلتها الابحار
شمالا باتجاه ميناء السويس كما اعلنت
الشركه تعليق كل عمليات الابحار عبر البحر
الاحمر لمده 48
ساعه انضم الينا من صنعاء مراسل الجزيره
محمد العطاب
محمد اذا تفاصيل كثيره حدثت في البحر
الاحمر هذه هذه خلال ه هذه الساعات
الفائته حدثنا عن
المعلن خلال هذه الساعات الفائ حدثنا عن
المعلن في ظل ما تصفه جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيون تراجع بارجتين امريكيتين ونقلهما
الى البحر المتوسط
و من البحر الاحمر الى البحر المتوسط وهم
السفينتين الحربيتين وبرم مايتين وهي يو
اس اس بيتن ويو اس اس كارتر هول بعد قرابه
خمسه اشهر فقط من ارساله ما الى المنطقه
البحر الاحمر وحسب خبراء يرون بان ذلك
التحالف الدولي المراد تشكيله بانه لحتى
الان لم يتشكل بذات التشكيله التي تريده
امريكا وكانه ولد وكانه مات يوم ولد حسب
اعتماد بعض المحللين والذي لا يزال ايضا
يهدف الى انهاء تهديد الحوثيين للملاحه
الدوليه وها نحن اليوم ايضا نشهد عمليه
اعلنت عنها القياده الوسطى الامريكيه عن
شني جماعه انصار الله ايضا هجوما على
سفينه وهي السفينه الشحنه التابعه لمارس
وايضا استهدافهم لمروحيات وقيام المروحيات
البحريه الامريكيه ايضا باستهداف هذه
الزوارق ولكن هنا نؤكد بانه لا يزال هناك
ايضا الرؤيه او
الروايه من انصار الله الحوثيين لم يؤكدوا
هذه العمليه ايضا فقط اكد مصدر ملاحي انهم
مستمرين في عملياتهم لمنع السفن الذاهبه
الى اسرائيل وايضا هنا نتحدث ايضا عن انه
فيما فقد لدينا ايضا مصدر الملاحيه الذي
اكد وقوع عدد من العمليات لمنع السفن
المتجه الى المواني الاسرائيليه وهو ايضا
ما اعلنتها القياده الوسطى وتاكد جماعه
انصار الله انه من خلال الحشود التي تخرج
بشكل اسب وهي تطالب جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين ايضا بالمزيد من العمليات للضغط
على اسرائيل والسماح بدخول الغذاء والدواء
وانهاء عدوانها على غزه ودعى مسؤول حوثي
ايضا بتكرار ذات الضغط في البحر المتوسط
لمنع ايضا السفن المتجهه الى الموانئ
الاسرائيليه والقادمه من راس الرجاء
الصالح ويعتقد بان ذلك سيشكل ضغطا كبيرا
لانه ستكتمل حلقه او دائره الحصار ويؤمل
بانها رضخ اسرائيل حسب وصفه لمطالبهم وهي
فتح المعابر وانهاء العدوان على غزه فنحن
الان امام تصاعد للاحداث ككل الطرفين
لديهما عزيمه وتصميم على تنفيذ ما ما يره
ما يرونه مناسبا فانص الله ترى ان عليها
مسؤوليه اخلاقيه ودينيه للوقوف مع اخوانهم
في فلسطين فيما واشنطن ترى ان تنقذ ان
تنفذ عمليات ما اسمتها حارس الازدهار وهو
بروسبر تي جارديان من خلال فرض ايقاف
لعمليه انصار الله الحوثيين في البحر
الاحمر ولذلك يقول انصار الله بانهم بان
امريكا بهذا التوجه هي من تستهدف امن
الملاحه في البحر الاحمر بعدم ضغطها على
حليفتها اسرائيل بادخال الغذاء والدواء
وتعد هذه العمليه من الاستهداف لسفن وهي
العمليه العاشره منذ 30 من نوفمبر يوم
اعلان الحصار على الموانئ
الاسرائيليه شرا شكرا لك مراسلنا من صنعاء
محمد العطاب